sortie la semaine dernière la biographie
du prince Harry rend fou le monde entier
et bah déjà tous les records 130 000
exemplaires en trois jours
avait déjà fuité dans la presse il y a
quelques jours Harry et Williams se sont
battus
les 544 pages de ce livre événement sont
désormais toutes disponibles perte de sa
mère sexe drogue tension Harry se livre
surtout et sans tabou de quoi faire
trembler encore un peu plus le palais de
Buckingham un livre d'une honnêteté
brute et sans farce si je cite notre
éditeur il y a des bons mais ça va
saigner ça se passe très bien alors que
contient c'est incroyable autobiographie
engouement planétaire pour le livre
d'Harry tous les extraits chocs révélé
ce soir dans TPMP
on va vous donner ce soir
avec Lakers les 10 choses à retenir les
19h50 on est en direct la première chose
à retenir
un des extraits qui a le plus fait
parler ou dans la foi c'est la terre
Castion entre Harry Williams qui en
serait même venu aux mains William
aurait qualifié Mégane de difficile
grossière et abrasive il a cru que c'est
un parquet flottant quoi la meuf non
mais sans rien abrasive de quoi ça on
est où là il aura ensuite attaqué Harry
il dit tout s'est passé si vite donc
très rapide si c'est si vite c'est que
c'est rapide il m'a attrapé par le col
déchirant mon collier il m'a jeté au sol
j'ai atterri sur la gamelle du chien qui
s'est fissuré sur mon dos la gamelle pas
le chien
les morceaux me coupant je suis resté là
un moment hébétique puis je me suis levé
et je lui ai dit de sortir c'est bien
raconter alors c'est immense on l'avait
évoqué ça se passe à natingham cottage
et William vient pour la troisième fois
déjà en réalité il tombe sur Harry mais
surtout ce qu'il veut tomber sur Mégane
c'est Meghan Markle qu'il cherche et
pourquoi est-ce qu'il gère William ce
jour-là
pardon particulièrement il veut dire à
Meghan Markle qu'il faut vraiment
qu'elle se calme puisque il y a de plus
en plus de bruit qui circulent au du
staff qui bosse pour eux ou un média
qualifié d’affernal et il y a du manque
de papa
avec son personnel elle aurait eu
certains termes qui ont été prononcées
voilà qui sera un peu difficile le
deuxième chose dans le livre le prince
Harry revient sur un des moments les
plus polémiques de sa jeunesse en 2005
une image de lui avec un déguisement
d'officier nazi a été publié dans la
presse il raconte comment lui est venu
l'idée j'ai parcouru ses interminables
rangés de portant examiner les costumes
suspendus sans rien trouver qui me
conviennent comme je n'avais plus
beaucoup de temps j'ai fini par
m'arrêter sur deux choix possibles un
uniforme de pilote de l'armée
britannique et un uniforme nazi couleur
sable avec un brassard à croix gammée et
une casquette plate uniforme d'Asie
voilà je l'ai loué ainsi qu'une fausse
moustache pour en rajouter une couche
dans le ridicule et je suis rentré à la
maison j'ai essayé mon costume Kate et
Willy ont hurlé de rire absolument
celui-là que tu dois choisir et pas
l'autre donc ils sont en train de nous
dire que en somme bah c'est William et
Kate à cette heure faute à eux s'il
portait ce fameux uniforme nazi mais
vous savez tout ce que l'on avait quel
âge il avait il était jeune à l'époque
il était genre il a il est pas encore
parti en Afghanistan
à l'époque
leurs amis qui a participé à ce fameux
anniversaire donc comme quoi c'était pas
pour moi
[Rires]
la tête voilà c'est vous savez moi je
l'ai lu à Cyril j'ai lu les 534 je
reviens un peu sur ce que j'ai dit je
nécessite vous le savez bien ici de
cracher sur Harry la franchement le
livre est divinement écrit superbement
écrit celui qui fait aussi
qui a obtenu le prix
il y a des couleurs il y a des saisons
il y a des sentiments il y a Diana en
fil rouge enfile conducteur et en
permanence il va surfer sur cette sur
cette vague de Diana alors je sais pas
ici pour parler de moi mais une toute
petite moi aussi oui moi aussi j'ai
perdu ma mère j'étais jeune moi aussi
dans des circonstances voilà qui ont été
difficiles donc je vous assure que
lorsque
on se dépose tous elles sont
universelles ces questions là qu'est-ce
qu'il dit Cyril en gros il dit je
refusais c'était tellement violent que
je refusais de croire qu'elle était
morte tout simplement parce que je ne
l'avais pas vu de mes yeux vu il va
s'auto persuader que Diana en gros elle
a trouvé un système pour échapper à la
presse aux médias ce milieu à ne
supportait pas et il va avoir des signes
permanents et ben c'est terriblement
bien fait dès la première phrase on
tombe dedans la première phrase c'est le
passé n'est jamais mort il n'est même
jamais passé alors l'autre monde du
livre important c'est l'Afghanistan et
les 25 tuiles a aussi été militaire a
été envoyé sur le terrain on Afghanistan
et n'hésite pas à raconter qu'il aurait
tué 25 cibles dans la chaleur et le
brouillard du combat c'est 25 cibles à
battus ne m'a pas resté pas comme des
personnes sans ça on ne peut pas tuer on
ne peut pas blesser ce n'était pas des
gens mais des pièces d'un jeu d'échec
qu'on faisait disparaître du plateau des
méchants qu'on supprimés avant qu'il tue
des gentils et il dit que la plus loin
il dit si jamais la pression que en
effet c'était un jeu vidéo parce que je
tirais un peu sur des pions électriques
mais c'est grave c'est gravissime ce
qu'il dit parce qu'en réalité est-ce que
vous imaginez maintenant les menaces qui
pèsent sur lui voilà de la part de la
vie à distance de la part des talibans
ce sont devenus en effet presque on dit
que ces deux enfants vous savez archi et
millimètre elle n'ose plus vraiment
sortir et elles ont une lumière rouge en
permanence sur le donc ça c'est terrible
quand on sait on le rappelle grosse
problématique la sécurité du couple
n'est plus prise en compte par
quitter la famille royale et que
désormais c'est eux qui doivent la payer
en face ça va alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe non non je dis ça
va ils ont quand même assez d'argent ils
ont bien vendu leur truc 100 millions 80
millions alors que pour le livre on
parle de 20 millions c'est totalement
faux les chiffres viennent vraiment de
tomber ils ont touché 40 millions de
dollars d'avaloir pour le livre
c'est énorme
10 millions d'exemplaires vendus donc 16
pays et la première c'est le record
historique
d'éditions fayards qui ont décroché le
Lore que toutes les maisons d'édition
bravo Fayard c'est Hachette alors que
toutes les maisons d'édition était sur
le coup et Fayard a donné quoi dans une
enveloppe fermée Fayard parce que ça se
ça c'est Dilé comme ça ça ira proposé un
million un million d'euros c'est Fayard
qui en effet a décroché la chose la nuit
dernière il gêne de retirer 18
exemplaires
ils ont vendu 85000 exemplaires ce qui
est un succès colossal sachant que Obama
c'était 35000 donc on voit le l'intérêt
incroyable
on salue Marie parce que c'est un peu
aussi il faut le reconnaître Harry le
magnifique quand on sait que dans les
livres du mal tu adorent mais oui les
bâches pourquoi parce que je l'ai dit
j'ai l'impression que je veux changer
d'âne
qui change pas d'avis j'ai un peu changé
d'avis parce que il a morflé il a
souffert il faut le reconnaître là où je
suis pas d'accord c'est qu'est-ce qu'il
a besoin d'aller balancer sur les autres
qu'est-ce qu'on s'en fout savoir que
William et circonscient est-ce qu'on
s'en fout de savoir qu'il puait l'alcool
au matin de son mariage parce que ça
puisqu'il nous raconte aussi alors il
déclare si il parle de la mort de Diana
il dit que son père ne l'a pas du tout
serré dans ses bras ça c'est un moment
fort papa ne m'a pas embrassé il n'était
pas doué pour montrer ses émotions dans
des circonstances normales comment
pouvait-on s'attendre à ce qu'il démonte
dans une telle crise Samant est tombé
une fois de plus sur mon genou il a dit
ça va aller c'est beaucoup pour lui
paternel plein d'espoir gentil et
tellement fou on revient de le match
il faut rappeler que Charles III
lorsqu'il est enfant il a 4 ans sa mère
elle part pour préserve non de voyage
visiter le Commonwealth et quand elle
rentre après ça ah non de Tournai elle
voit son fils et elle lui serre la main
donc il revient de loin Charles il n'a
pas de côté en effet humain c'est très
difficile le côté humain pour les
Windsor une seule chose compte c'est
l'apparence il faut le reconnaître
Charles qu'est-ce qu'il dit aussi c'est
assez touchant il dit comme mon père
c'est très bien qu'il est pas dans le
verbal qu'il n'est pas dans l'expression
et ben il m'écrivait des lettres qu'il
déposait sur mon or et j'aurais préféré
que l'on en parle alors il a eu le pénis
gelé aussi le bout de la dur il a eu un
problème de zizi lors d'une exposition
au Pôle Nord il dit j'ai décrit les
dysfonctionnements cascade tout est
difficile monsieur m'asseoir marcher les
relations sexuelles il dit mon zizi me
faisait l'effet d'être toujours au garde
à vous un jour il y a même un une
personne dans l'expédition qui a pris
mon zizi pour un Mr Freeze
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il a vraiment eu le zizi je l'ai il a eu
le zizi je l'ai et alors ça il raconte
cette histoire là au matin du mariage
maintenant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le jour du mariage de Katie William le
monde entier s'est focalisé sur les
fesses de Pippa Middleton
pourquoi alors je suis pas comme toi tu
es tu es extrême tu es passionné c'est
fantastique il faut savoir qu'en fait
ils ont été black bol et on l'a coupé
les vivres en Angleterre puisque Mégane
était une femme très excentrique et
parce que c'était une Movistar et
qu'elle était à son deuxième mariage et
donc pas accepter par la famille royale
la grand-mère l'adorait mais à chaque
fois on leur bloquait le chemin pour
qu'il puisse pas directement parler à la
grand-mère donc Oprah Winfrey qui était
donc une amie de Mégane les a présenté
un jet privé et les a emmener à Santa
Barbara dans une maison afin de pouvoir
produire ce document sur Netflix
puisqu'il plus d'argent et cette dame
Mégane lui a fait tourner la tête et
effectivement c'est devenu un rebelle sa
mère était rebelle donc voilà il joue en
fait ce côté rock n' roll je ne je ne
serai pas comme comme mon frère et j'ai
envie en fait de pouvoir m'exprimer et
oui je sors avec une femme qui est
métissée et qui est mariée et alors je
fais ce que je veux et je m'en fous vous
me couper les villes je ferai un livre
je serai nombreux dans mon document
Netflix
n'aura jamais rien de gelé parce que là
réécrire le compte il veut pas parler
tous les deux les chiens
raconte aussi dans des termes sans
équivoque sa toute première fois
apparemment regardez ça toute première
fois un épisode de tout récent un peu
glorieux ma toute première fois c'était
avec Jeanne Mas euh
avec une femme plus âgée elle aimait les
chevaux passionnément elle m'avait
traité un peu comme un jeune étalon un
rapide débourrage une petite tape sur la
croupe et hop elle m'avait renvoyé au
paddock un détail parmi tous ce nombre
qui a fait cette expérience à désastre
ça s'est passé dehors dans un champ
d'herbe et quand je me suis réveillé
j'avais du blé dans le cul
manifestement quelqu'un nous avait vu
apparemment quelqu'un les avait vu ben
non non parce que c'est lui qui c'est
c'est lui qui dit manifestement
quelqu'un nous avait vu ne dis pas s'il
a utilisé de capotes plat à craquer avec
une femme qui était beaucoup plus âgée
que lui oui voilà donc vous savez ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire alors et
d'ailleurs il donne le prénom de la
meufs non italienne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voyez que les éditions Penguin c'est le
nom de sa maison d'édition et bien et
exiger vous savez il y a un contrat
parfaitement ficelé on l'imagine en
disant ok d'accord on dépose les 20
millions qui se sont métamorphosés en 40
millions de dollars sur la table mais on
attend tu sais que ça a été vraiment un
des délirants qui a été exigé par la
maison d'édition ouais
comme comme
les deux les deux et William sont
circoncis c'est qui c'est quelle race
parce que c'est des rats en fait c'est
qui c'est le rêve le RAV4
[Rires]
est-ce qu'ils peuvent se réconcils on
parle de réconciliation actuellement
parce que est-ce que c'est vrai ou
est-ce que c'est faux j'ai pas de boule
de cristal alors moi j'ai envie de vous
répondre que non parce que on imagine
mal est-ce que vous imaginez les deux
clans qui vont se réunir et les winds
qui vont dire mais la moindre chose que
l'on va pouvoir dire risque de se
retrouver je prends une fraise dans un
livre ou et en même temps l'information
date d'hier que nous révèle le déni
Telegraphe que tout compte fait il a ils
ont obtenu une interview de Harry et il
dit mais vous savez au final à la
relecture j'ai supprimé plus de 300
pages non il va faire un top 2 il va
prendre 40 balles je trouvais que
c'était trop compris et que mon père et
mon frère ne m'aurait jamais pardonné
moi ce que je pense que ça n'engage que
moi Cyril à l'heure actuelle c'est que
il va tenter une négociation il va
tenter quelque chose et ça laisse dire
aux Windsor ok si vous n'acceptez pas
vous savez quand même que j'ai déjà 60
par personne écrite des bâtards et elle
sera bah oui
c'est un bâtard
c'est un besoin d'argent que le
comprendre qu'ils ont quitté la famille
royale tout le monde doit gagner sa vie
c'est tout à fait d'accord mais qu'on ne
le fasse pas un larbin comme un rejeton
comme le raté de la famille pardon mais
excusez-moi c'est bien fait pour eux en
fait c'est bien on ne dit pas qu'il a
été rejeté qu'il a été traité comme à
l'arbal c'est pas vraiment ce qu'il dit
sa femme a été a été maltraité quand
même par là que moi ce qui m'embête
j'aurais dit c'est que pourquoi je
cracher sur une institution qui ne qui
est réduite au silence qui ne peut pas
parler qui les circonscient il a envie
de nous raconter ma foi
[Musique]
calme-toi aussi et William aussi
pourquoi pourquoi
ok d'accord c'est une biographie qu'il
engage lui mais pourquoi mouiller la
famille royale à ce point alors qu'il
sait très bien que techniquement la
famille royale
pas possible c'est à quoi boulevard
là-bas
le couronnement sans doute bien sûr
c'est qu'encouragement négociation
ils ont pas fait la galette des rois
[Rires]
le 6 mai prochain on attend ben voilà de
le monde entier va avoir les yeux rivés
moi j'ai envie de dire que non mais avec
les informations que l'on a depuis
quelques jours peut-être merci en tout
cas
rien du tout quand même